now while all of this mega news has been
unfolding i actually turned my hands to
something slightly different i've
written a piece for the website today
which is a preview of a big bbc two
documentary two parts big budget about
inequality and it's called the decade
the rich one and one of the things the
program focuses in on is this policy of
quantitative easing which is when
central banks around the world pumped
loads of money into the economy in a
particular way that ended up benefiting
people who owned assets so shares in
companies or companies themselves or
property or pensions
and one of the contributors to the
documentary maybe actually even the star
of the documentary he is a inequality
economist who's a former trader who made
loads of money and now has very strong
opinions his name is gary stevenson and
he's here now hi gary hi adam i feel
like i've been watching you on tv quite
a lot documentary and people will have
seen you on tv now as well um so there's
loads we can talk about i mean first of
all just your story going from kind of
poacher turned gamekeeper a bit what was
what was that about well i mean i always
wanted to work in the city growing up um
i grew up in east london pretty poor
background you know good at maths good
at economics it's that straight line
into the city i went to lsc and i was
working in the city i started working in
june 2008 which is obviously everybody
will know just a few months before the
crisis blew up and uh my job was to bet
on interest rates
so um for those who don't know interest
rates collapsed to zero all over the
world in 2008 and suddenly my job and
the job of people like me was to bit on
when will rates come up which is
to simplify quite a lot basically a bit
on when will the economy recover and um
the history of this is fascinating
actually because in 2008 when the crisis
happened everybody bet rates were up in
2009. and in 2009 they thought it'd be
2010 in 2010 it was 2011 in 2011 it was
2012 and at the beginning of 2020 before
kovid they were betting rates for
normalized later that year so for 12
consecutive years these guys bet the
recovery would be next year and um after
sort of two three years of seeing
everyone be wrong you start thinking
well what's really going on and i sort
of really delved into the question of
why aren't rates going up why is the
economy not recovering
what is happening that we're not getting
and i basically came to the conclusion
that economists and traders were just
not understanding how important
inequality was so if i was right and
inequality is a problem it's not going
to get fixed the economy will not
recover so i went back to my desk and
put a massive bet on that we would never
have a recovery and by the end of that
year 2011 i was citibank's most
profitable trader in the world how much
money did you make for the bank in that
uh i made 35 million dollars for the
bank that year wow but it's a you know i
made that money by betting that really
bad things would happen in the economy
and um you know the bank paid me a big
sum of money and then they said well
done mate do it again next year and um
there's only so many years you can do
that i think especially if you come from
a poor background and it's your it's
your family and your friends that are
being affected
before you start thinking you know if
i'm really the best at this if i'm
really right in my understanding then
surely i have to talk about it and to
tell people yeah okay right there's lots
of things we need to untangle there and
it takes this documentary like two hours
to do that so we'll do the short version
but let's start off with one of the
reasons for the low interest rates was
obviously like central banks deciding to
keep interest rates low because they
decide what they are it's not just like
a force of nature but also they were
kept low by this thing called
quantitative easing qe have you ever
managed to do a quick way of explaining
what qe is to people who aren't familiar
with it i could try controlling this
i mean essentially it's a system of
long-term loans basically usually the uh
central bank keeps rates low by doing
short-term loans to commercial banks
like lloyds or halifax but in this
instance after 2008 they thought that
wasn't enough we need to lend more money
to the system long term and the way they
do that is they look at people who own
government bonds and government bonds
are loans to the government so as we
know the government borrows a lot of
money and that comes from pension funds
from wealthy individuals from sovereign
wealth funds big investment funds and
these are long-term loans five years ten
years in quantitative easing the central
bank basically buys those loans off of
the people who have lent money to the
government so say you've lent money to
the british government for 10 years
suddenly the central bank the bank of
england comes in buys that loan from you
and now you're sitting on the cash so
people who let money for the government
suddenly get their money now
and that brings interest rates very low
because suddenly all of this money is
pushed back into system right now so
suddenly all the investment funds have
loads of money now and they need to
think what are we going to do with it is
that simple enough that's pretty good
actually yeah yeah it's not a simple
thing to explain yeah and the whole idea
is that it keeps the cost of borrowing
low and keeps the supply of money in the
system high so therefore banks will lend
to businesses that need it and
businesses can get a loan at a cheaper
rate than maybe they would have done
otherwise and that's meant to stimulate
the economy but as um guy hands he's
quite a famous financial guy he's the
founder of terra firma capital partners
says in this documentary he's quite
honest about what that did for people
who already owned quite a lot of stuff
the government just poured enormous
quantities of money into the system
those of us in private equity
got incredibly wealthy in some ways it's
obvious if you plonk a whole lot of
money into the system
it's going to end up going to those
who've got money
but in some ways it's not and that the
way it's not is the government assumes
that money goes in and it gets spread
equally
rather than realizing that money goes in
and it gets attracted to money if you've
got money and more money appears
you will get it
and then there's a really interesting
bit when george osborne who of course
was the chancellor during the tory
libdam coalition when quantitative
easing was really getting going having
been started by alistair darling he says
this he's kind of quite honest about
what the effect of qe was on on lots of
other people well qb is really difficult
there's printing money because its
purpose is that people who already have
something like a house or a pension or
some shares
will see the value of those things go up
that that's what the policy is designed
to do
and it feels unfair because the people
who don't have those things
aren't getting the benefits of the
policy but ultimately i came to the
conclusion it's better to try and
keep the economy floating rather than
let everything crash and that's the
defense you hear from all former
chancellors who've been involved in this
from alistair darling up to now that
quantitative easing was necessary to
just keep the financial system going
when it was teetering on the brink now
just explain to me why is it that
putting this extra money into the system
means that people who have assets like
pensions or houses or shares and things
end up getting more money i can't quite
work out the link from a to b so the
money gets into the system by the
central bank the bank of england buying
loans to the government okay well who
owns loans to the government it's
investment funds and more than anything
else it's wealthy individuals you know
the more money you have the more money
you've done to the government basically
so the money at the first point it goes
into the system it's going to investment
funds and wealth individuals okay and um
wealth individuals are not going to go
straight into the shops and spend that
money you know very wealthy people when
they get money they invest it that's
that's what very wealthy people do and
so straight away it's going to push up
stock prices and house prices before
2008 we all used to think
bad economy stock prices down house
prices down there was a guy sitting next
to me a trader and he was like look it
was about 2010. i was like the economy
is doing terribly stock just go up and
up and up i'm going to short stocks and
i turn around and i said look stocks
can't go down they cannot go down
because if the economy is weak the
central bank will print money and if the
economy is strong they'll go up you know
so
if you give the money to investors they
will invest it yeah and that doesn't
support the economy supports asset
prices uh there's also some stuff in the
documentary just about the culture in
the places that you used to work and you
tell this story about this kind of away
day that you that you had
you're near the story yeah i've actually
brought the hat with me but if you
didn't see it yeah you could see i
thought you might ask yeah why don't you
go and get it right gary's gonna now go
and take his mic off and go and open his
bag
and then i'll let you sit down and put
your mic back on yeah
now i'm going to be intrigued to see how
you get this cap on over the top of the
headset mike but let's give it a go so
yeah they used to have an away day for
the trailers once a year don't put this
on now on now yeah and it's not going to
fit i think it's not exactly well i can
see it anyway so yes and it says go pick
or go home go bigger so i think this was
the beginning of 2011. we had an away
day for the traders and uh all the
traders sit back traders from all over
the world come to this one away though
and we walked in and straight away they
gave us these hats and this hats down
the front go big or go home it's a
little sort of army camera hat for those
who can't see and um
senior management sat down and they said
look if you think you're a good trader
and you're willing to take a risk in a
million dollars why not take it in 10
million you know go big or go home and i
i couldn't i couldn't believe that it's
it's just
it beggars belief really so you know
afterwards all the traders went back and
massively up their risk and then as soon
as they lose a bit of money they lose 10
times what they used to lose and they
have to stop their positions out and it
was a disaster and that's why you know
one of the reasons why i was citibank's
top trade in 2011 is because all the
other traders got given these hats and
started taking massively too much risk
but it's um it's unbelievably
responsible but the thing is there's
this problem that goes all the way
through the system which is if you're an
individual trader and you make loads of
money you get paid loads of money but if
you lose loads of money you're not
personally liable and your boss is the
same right and his boss is the same and
his boss is the same and then what 2008
showed us is literally the entire bank
is the same yeah all the way through the
system every individual right up to
senior management to the entire
corporation is taking the profits when
they win and it goes to the government
when they lose and if this sounds to
people a bit like ancient history
because we're talking about 2008 2011
actually it's not because qe was done
again on a massive scale at the start of
the pandemic and it's still being done
now so you're seeing the same thing
enormous 450 billion which is 10 000
pounds for every single adult in the
country so if you're not sitting on ten
thousand pounds more then you were pre
covered someone else has got your ten
thousand pounds and i put videos out
right at the beginning of of coburg
saying look this is gonna cause big
increases in inequality big increases in
stock prices big increases in house
prices and big increases in inflation
and i think we really need to ask why is
it that governments and economists feel
the only thing they can do in crisis is
to pump money in and make the rich
unbelievably richer you know the first
year of kovid was the biggest ever
single year increase in billionaire
wealth in this country during the
biggest economic disaster after the war
you know is that right why is it that
we've created a system where when
there's a crisis the richest profit
massively rather than
paying higher taxes and then what we're
seeing now in march is national
insurance being raised and that's taxed
on ordinary workers that does not apply
to the income of millionaires in the
united states but i think george osborne
says in the documentary okay the rich
may have got richer and people might
feel uncomfortable about that because
not everyone got to participate in that
but he says average wages
did okay and so actually it's not like
the rich getting richer and the poor are
getting poorer it is just the rich
getting did they do okay relative to the
cost of basic goods and services you
know you don't need a degree in
economics to see that okay yeah wages
didn't collapse like they didn't say the
great depression
but the cost of basic goods and services
was there was really high inflation in
2011 i don't think i don't know if you
remember it you went up to sort of five
six percent you know and basically where
we are now
what is amazing to me is that fewer
people in the media are saying look it's
a replay of 2008 we're doing the same
thing we're pumping money in it's going
to the rich and sure that keeps your
wages up but it also makes it's going to
make house prices double it pushes the
cost of food and energy up why is it
that we feel that we're not allowed to
tax the rich we feel the only way to
deal with an economic crisis is to pump
money in economists have sort of tied
their hands and you know it must be
mentioned that we have a chance to lose
i've got an estimated worth of 200
million pounds and yet when there's a
crisis it's never mentioned well maybe
the richard actually contribute and what
actually ends up happening 2008 and
kovid is a massive increase in the
wealth of the riches but nonetheless qe
being taken away is seems to be causing
problems as well because actually
they're starting to withdraw it now
aren't they yeah and you know i think qe
is a complicated one because we saw a
period where the rich got massively
richer and it would be easy to say well
that's because of qe we should have done
qe but actually without qe i think
probably we would have seen 2008 play
out a lot more like the great depression
and i think qe probably prevented that
but the problem is with qe it prevents
some of the worst problems but it causes
massive increasing inequality massive
increase in the wealth of the richest
massive increase in house prices and
stock prices so
qe is a great way to save us at times of
extreme need and nothing illustrates
that better than what happened in covid
it causes huge amounts of money to put
up with the richest and if you don't go
in afterwards and then tax the richest
you see exactly what we're seeing now
big increase in house prices big
increase in inflation and a massive
falling standard of living so do the qe
accept that it's going to cause a
massive increase in equality but you
have to tax the richest afterwards
otherwise you're going to get this
massive decrease in standard of living
it should be obvious then we could do a
whole other podcast into our documentary
series on the right level of tax for for
the rich as as you're talking about
there anyway gary thank you so much i
can see why you were so suited to being
a trader because your brain works like a
million miles an hour thank you
hopefully that's good
well that's all for this episode of
newscast i have a sneaking suspicion the
news is just about to take off at a
million miles an hour as well
good luck everyone bye newscast newscast
from the bbc well thank you for making
it to the end of another newscast you
clearly ooze stamina and i gently
encourage you to subscribe to us on bbc
sounds and then without having to do
anything else our meandering chats will
miraculously make its way to your phone
you